SIERRA: Hip Hop.
We all know it.
And we can’t turn on the radio or go to
a party without hearing it.
It’s an American artform - born in the Bronx,
and audible from coast to coast.
But in recent decades, hip hop has gone global.
And at this point, almost every country on
earth has developed its own style of the genre.
[Global Hip-hop Montage]
SIERRA: Hip-Hop is a global culture.
It's also a multi-billion dollar business
fueled by artists all over the world.
Still, American artists dominate the genre,
and this presents a unique opportunity for
cultural diplomacy.
Yeah, it may be surprising, but for years,
the US State Department has been capitalizing
on the power of hip-hop, sending musical ambassadors
abroad to forge connections.
I’m Gabrielle Sierra and this is Why It
Matters.
Today, hip-hop diplomacy, and the enduring
legacy of America’s musical soft power.
BLACKMAN: I think the concept behind soft
power is that instead of being aggressive
or right in someone's face, is that you are
more subtle with the idea of relationship
building.
SIERRA: This is Toni Blackman.
She’s a rapper, an educator, and cultural
ambassador.
She was the first Hip Hop Diplomat for the
U.S. State Department.
Today she continues to do official musical
diplomacy, with an organization called Next
Level, and another that she founded: Rhyme
like a Girl.
BLACKMAN: And so, eventually I believe the
way it connects to foreign policy is that
policy decisions are made not only based upon
the policy itself, but rooted in relationships,
right?
It's very easy for musicians and artists to
be able to create a dialogue, and that dialogue
then spreads out, in terms of peoples' attitudes,
and impressions, and their view, their perspective
on America.
SIERRA: For more than a hundred years, American
music and pop culture have been remarkably
popular abroad.
I mean think about it, Americans created blues,
jazz, rock and roll, motown, R&B, and now
hip-hop.
And with each of these waves, musicians abroad
were inspired to create their own versions.
All along, the State Department has attempted
to capitalize on this popularity, and consolidate
this musical soft power via diplomatic programs
that sponsored concerts and cultural exchanges
around the world.
BLACKMAN: It’s about advancing the interest
of the country, at the end of the day.
But, it's also about improving the relationships.
There's a humanitarian aspect to the work.
And, it's one of the reasons why I admire
foreign service workers so much.
The end goal really is about influence.
It is about power, but it's also about culture,
and it's about connection and community.
And promoting peace.
SIERRA: You have the coolest job that maybe
I've ever heard in the whole world, so I can't
wait to dive into it.
But before we do, how would you define hip-hop?
BLACKMAN: I would define hip-hop as a music
and art culture.
A lot of time, when people use the term hip-hop
they think about rap.
But, rap is only one small part of what hip-hop
music and culture is.
There is the rap, there is the DJing, there
is dance, there is the visual art.
Not only graffiti writing, but in terms of
mural making.
And, fashion design.
Fashion is a big part of what hip-hop culture
has given birth to.
There is vocal percussion, better known as
beatboxing and making music with your mouth.
And so, when people teach hip-hop 101 they
say, "There are four core elements of hip-hop.
Rap, dance, DJing, and graffiti."
But, now it's expanded over the years and
there's a whole movement globally of hip-hop
heads, of artists who are committed to doing
activism around climate change and spiritual
and mental health.
KATZ: Hip hop is a cultural form that originated
in the United States but is strongly connected
with African-American and African diasporic
cultures around the world and grew up in the
1970s and is about to celebrate its 50th birthday
if you take the usual birth date of August
11th, 1973, as its official birthday.
SIERRA: This is Mark Katz, he is an author
and a professor of music at the University
of North Carolina.
He’s the founder of Next Level, and has
worked closely with Toni on musical diplomacy
for years.
SIERRA: What's that day?
KATZ: So that was the day that is considered
the first hip hop party that was thrown by
DJ Kool Herc in an apartment building in the
south Bronx.
And although it wasn't called hip hop at the
time, we look back at that moment as an event
that started what hip hop became.
SIERRA: Can you tell me a little bit about
what you do?
KATZ: Since 2013, I have been associated with
what I consider to be a very important cultural
diplomacy program run out of the State Department's
Bureau of Educational and Cultural Affairs.
And the program is called Next Level, and
it sends US hip hop artists around the world
to make people-to-people connections with
citizens of other countries, to promote a
more positive image of the US, to create mutual
understanding.
And I have had the pleasure and privilege
of traveling to dozens of countries around
the world with this program and being able
to see up close how music brings people together
who might otherwise have no real connections.
SIERRA: Hip-hop’s global popularity didn’t
just spring up overnight.
It was a long road.
So here’s a quick history for those who
need it: In 1979, The Sugar Hill Gang released
Rappers Delight, the first hip hop single
to chart in the Top 40.
In the 1980s, hip hop artists like LL Cool
J, Salt N Peppa, Rakim and Public Enemy took
the genre to new heights.
In 1986, Run DMC released the first platinum
hip hop album, gaining crossover appeal through
a collaboration with Aerosmith.
By the 1990s, hip hop gained notoriety for
perceived misogyny and violence in rap lyrics.
At the same time, a series of groundbreaking
rappers rose to global prominence.
Tupac Shakur and the Notorious BIG both released
albums that sold more than 10 million copies
worldwide, that’s a platinum record ten
times over.
At the end of the decade, Lauryn Hill became
the first hip hop artist to receive a Grammy
for Album of the year.
By the early 2000s, Eminem and Outkast had
also released diamond records, and it was
becoming commonplace to hear these artists
celebrated on radio stations around the world.
As love for the genre grew, hip hop scenes
in places like France, the UK, and many parts
of Africa were maturing in their own right,
setting the groundwork for global hip hop
as we know it today.
Last year hip hop and R&B recordings were
streamed more than 290 billion times worldwide.
BLACKMAN: I've been to one city in the world
on planet Earth where they didn't know who
Tupac was.
They didn't know the references.
That was on the island of Aceh in Indonesia.
It was fascinating to me because that was
the only time in my life where I had that
occurrence.
But, it's big.
And it's expressed in different ways, in different
cultures.
But, the culture is very much alive around
the world.
SIERRA: Do you think that there are themes
in hip hop that make it particularly relatable
to so many different people worldwide?
KATZ: There are a lot of different themes
that connect with people around the world
who may have never been to the US or speak
English or have any particular connection
to American culture.
And that’s because hip hop on the global
stage connects with very deeply held human
drives, the drive to express oneself, the
drive to celebrate one's joys and wins and
victories, the drive to protest injustice,
and simply the drive to show what it means
to be a human living in the world.
And hip hop does that really well.
It does that because anyone can access hip
hop, anyone who has a voice and a body can
create hip hop, and because it is connected
to a community of people in the US who had
to fight for recognition to get their voice
heard and creates a sense of solidarity among
people around the world who find themselves
in similarly oppressed situations.
SIERRA: Across borders, people have coalesced
around hip hop for decades.
One example was in 1991, Serbians living under
the Milošević regime, connected to the lyrics
of Public Enemy’s Fight the Power, it was
broadcast on repeat when traditional news
was banned.
KATZ: But it's particularly powerful for people
who don't have a voice that is recognized
outside of their immediate community or people
whose voices have been silenced or whose communities
have been marginalized or oppressed.
So that's the real connection that people
find that they're able to express their way
of life.
And not simply as protest, hip hop is often
talked about as protest music.
And that is true, but that's not all it is.
It's also party music.
It's also music that recognizes one's humanity
and celebrates just being alive.
SIERRA: The end result of this is that hundreds
of millions of people worldwide love hip hop.
And while we don’t usually talk about concepts
like love on this show, that kind of passion
is an important basis for soft power.
It’s an attachment that goes deep into many
people’s identities, and it opens up a door
for dialogue, and for nuanced perceptions
about what the United States means.
What’s interesting about this is that it
has happened many times before.
American music has a knack for capturing the
world’s heart - and as a result, the United
States government has long been in the business
of using music to promote its interests around
the globe.
Starting in 1956, the US State Dept.
sent world famous musicians like Dizzy Gilepse,
Louis Armstrong, and Duke Elington abroad
as jazz ambassadors.
Congressman Adam Clayton Powell Jr: We’re
going to shift the emphasis to jazz and send
these artists over where they can reach the
masses of the people in Asia and Africa and
one of the people who we’re planning to
use is my friend Dizzy Gillespie.
Reporter: What do you think about that, Dizzy?
Dizzy Gillespie: The weapon that we will use
is the cool one.
SIERRA: Can you tell me a bit of the history
of US music abroad and how it's intersected
with geopolitics and diplomacy?
KATZ: Cultural diplomacy and in particular
musical diplomacy has always been most strongly
backed and most frequently deployed in times
of threats to the US.
That at the height of those threats was also
the height of the State Department's deployment
of music and culture more generally abroad
as a way of using soft power.
So in the '30s, the State Department sent
the composer Aaron Copland to South America
to facilitate the good neighbor policy, to
make friends with South American countries
so that they wouldn't be taken over by fascists.
And of course, that's a simplification, but
basically that's what it was.
And then during the '50s after World War II
during the cold war, it was about pushing
back against communism.
And during that time, particularly the cold
war period, was when American popular music
came to be the primary medium of musical diplomacy.
Willis Conover: Hello Louis Armstrong, the
name which means America to more people than
anyone else I can think of, over a long period
of time.
What can you say about Louis, expect Louis
take it.
Louis Armstrong: Well…whatcha say gizzard[laughter]
ah my man!
KATZ: Before that it was actually more classical
music.
But starting in the '50s, a lot of jazz was
sent around the world as a way of creating
goodwill and doing a couple of things.
One was demonstrating that the US actually
had culture and pushing back against the Soviet
Union, which has a long history of operas,
ballet, symphonies and so on, and showing
a American born art form which was jazz, but
also in using jazz artists, many of whom are
African-American, as a way of demonstrating
the freedom that the US likes to say it has
and gives all of its citizens.
SIERRA: And the crowds loved it.
[1965, Hungarian crowd cheers for Louis Armstrong]
SIERRA: That crowd, by the way, was cheering
Louis Armstrong in Budapest, Hungary, a country
under Soviet sway where the opportunity to
see a western star was very rare indeed.
All around the world, jazz had come to symbolize
ideas of American freedom and its popularity
made Soviet leaders nervous.
During this time, radio hosts like Willis
Conover of Voice of America would transmit
jazz across the iron curtain via shortwave
technology.
Picture young, jazz-loving soviets tinkering
with their radio dials in private, hoping
to catch a few minutes of forbidden music.
SIERRA: It seems important to me that this
music has been celebrated by the world, even
used as a metaphor, as you say, for American
freedom, while these Black Americans were,
are, struggling for justice and recognition
in their home country.
So what thoughts do you have about that dynamic?
KATZ: Well, that has always been a really
complex dynamic, one that African-Americans
have been dealing with in many aspects of
life, representing their country but not feeling
represented by them.
So soldiers going off to war, civil servants,
teachers, and many other walks of life you
can say the same thing.
But in terms of music, this was very public
because these tours were covered by the media
around the world.
And so you have these juxtapositions of Emmett
Till being lynched and famous black jazz artists
performing around the world.
You had all these really stark juxtapositions
of what was touted as freedom when these musicians
were abroad, but then really horrific examples
of racism and oppression at home.
So this was something that the artist had
to navigate.
They had to decide whether they felt it was
appropriate for them personally to represent
their country given their lived experience,
whether it worked for them to accept regardless
of the oppression that they might have faced.
SIERRA: In fact, in 1962 Louis Armstrong and
Dave Brubeck released a song that expressed
their conflicted feelings about representing
the U.S. abroad.
Louis Armstrong: Who's the real ambassador?
Certain facts we can ignore; In my humble
way, I'm the USA!
Though I represent the government, the government
don't represent some policies I'm for!
KATZ: It's a complex calculus that I see still
happening today with hip hop artists who have
to ask themselves, do I want to be associated
with the government given how I feel the government
has treated my community?
And if so, why would I do that?
BLACKMAN: While they were representing America,
they also challenged America, in that, "I'm
good enough to represent you, but I'm not
good enough to walk through the front door
as a Black person."
Like, those questions were raised.
And then, they were able to see the world
themselves and to see how the world embraced
jazz music and jazz culture, another American
export.
But, that jazz diplomacy opened the door for
hip-hop diplomacy because there was a point
where the younger generations weren't tuning
into jazz, they weren't tuning into Americana
and bluegrass, but they were listening to
hip-hop.
SIERRA: I'd love to ask you a little bit more
about what you mentioned with the protest
aspect of hip hop.
Have you observed that playing out in interesting
ways abroad?
You know, is there an interesting connection
between protest rap abroad and the outrage
and oppression that's part of the DNA of American
hip hop?
KATZ: There is a strong connection between
hip hop and protest, and that's in part because
of the mythos that surrounds the birth of
hip hop.
Hip hop emerged in the US out of young people,
from communities of color, largely people
who had traditionally been oppressed within
their own country.
And so there is a knowledge not only that
hip hop is American but that it was born in
a way as a form of protest and of celebrating
life in difficult circumstances.
SIERRA: Songs by NWA and Public Enemy have
consistently been used in global protest movements
since they emerged in the 1980s.
Public Enemy: Fight the power, fight the power,
fight the power.
SIERRA: And During the Arab Spring, an artist
named Hamada Ben Amor used rap to criticize
the Tunisian government.
The song he wrote went viral, and became an
anthem for the movement.
During this era, artists like Omar Offendum
rapped in both Arabic and English to bring
the world’s attention to the revolution.
Omar Offendum: Freedom isn't given by oppressors/It's
demanded by oppressed/Freedom lovers, freedom
fighters/Free to gather and protest/For their
God-given rights/For the freedom of the press/We
know freedom is the answer/The only question
is…/Who’s next?
SIERRA: Then, fast forward to 2020, Kendrick
Lamar’s track “Alright” and Childish
Gambino’s “This is America” became synonymous
with the global 2020 Black Lives Matter marches.
Kendrick Lamar: This is America/Don't catch
you slippin' now/Don't catch you slippin'
now
SIERRA: And in recent months, some of Russia’s
most prominent rappers have been releasing
tracks that are viscerally critical of the
Russian invasion of Ukraine.
In one of these songs, star rapper Morgenshtern
sampled a real-life recording of a Ukrainian
mother telling her son that she was deciding
whether to run or seek shelter from the bombings.
Palagin’s mother (Russian): Сынулечка,
ну да, у нас тут, прям у нас,
утром и крышу чуть не снесло
Мы думали куда-то тикать,
а потом вернулись на место
Ну вот щас сидим, и в погребе
бомбоубежище себе приготовили
Так что, ну котик, не волнуйся.
Palagin’s mother (English): My dear son,
well yes, here, right here, in the morning
the roof was almost blown away, we thought
about running somewhere then we returned to
our place.
Well, right now we are sitting in the cellar,
we prepared a bomb shelter for ourselves.
So, well, oh baby, don't worry.
SIERRA: How do you think that love for hip-hop
interacts with people's thoughts about the
United States abroad?
KATZ: Loving hip hop doesn't automatically
mean you love the US.
There is no direct connection.
You can love American culture and hate the
US government.
You can love Hollywood movies and plot the
destruction of America.
All of those things are simultaneously possible.
Where the connection and the real power of
hip hop diplomacy is is in the people-to-people
connection.
BLACKMAN: I think it provides a calming effect,
in terms of the way people might feel about
certain politics.
And then, there's a softening that occurs
because then you got hip-hop.
For many it's a religion.
It is a sport.
It is a practice.
It is a part of their essence and who they
are.
Hip-hop heads don't play about the culture.
So, I think it does influence them in ways
that allow the government to be strategic,
to make strategic moves, that allows for younger
people, particularly new generations, to not
turn against the country, to have more balanced
critiques.
I think that's one of the things that hip-hop
does, and the hip-hop diplomacy does, is it
creates room for a balanced critique, particularly
if people have engaged directly with hip-hop
artists.
If they've engaged with the actual artists
who they were touching and talking to, and
looking in the eye, then that does create
a different sort of energy and vibration,
where there's a separation from the people
and the government, and they start to understand
that the American people aren't necessarily
in sync with the government at all time.
And I think that's actually a good thing.
SIERRA: Global opinion surveys continue to
show highly positive attitudes toward US exports
like music, movies, and popular culture.
By contrast, the US is perceived far more
negatively when it comes to things like healthcare
and the state of its democracy.
Being a global leader in music can seem like
a small victory - but it’s one that goes
deep.
When non-Americans hear hip hop - much of
which is critical of American life and society
- they are hearing evidence of a government
that allows itself to be criticized.
As experts on public diplomacy have noted,
that gives the United States an important
type of credibility, especially in contrast
to authoritarian countries like Russia and
China.
Soft power is power through attraction, and
on that front, hip hop has given the U.S.
a global edge.
KATZ: What I would love for this episode to
do is to reach people who are skeptical of
hip hop period but also skeptical of hip hop
as a platform for conducting diplomacy.
I once spoke with a very liberal Democratic
Senator and told him about Next Level and
he scoffed.
He said, "Why would we send hip hop abroad?"
And what I want to say is because it works.
If you care about creating goodwill around
the world, if you care about connecting with
communities that traditionally don't love
the US and traditionally hate US foreign policy,
then you would be smart to send hip hop artists
abroad.
SIERRA: Before we end, I would like to share
an experience that I’ve had.
So, I’ve been lucky enough to travel a lot
and one thing that’s been amazing to me,
is the amount of people who light up when
I specifically say that I am from Brooklyn,
New York.
That has a lot to do with hip hop.
I have had Biggie, Jay-Z and Lil’ Kim lyrics
sung to me on more than one occasion, and
even had a few DJ’s respond by throwing
on some classic hip hop hits.
The deep global love for American culture
is real, and it has been for a long time.
In previous generations it might have been
the Beach Boys, or Smokey Robinson that provoked
that special moment.
Our culture and especially our music connects
us to people around the world who otherwise
might feel no connection at all.
And right now, hip hop is one of the key forms
carrying on that tradition.
And that’s something that deserves our recognition.
SIERRA: Can you tell us just one story about
your travels as a hip hop diplomat?
BLACKMAN: In Senegal, people warned me to
be careful because it was, "A Muslim country.
And the men, be careful as a woman there.
You're going to be treated by the older...
Especially the older people."
I was at the National School of The Arts here
in Dakar, and I was speaking.
After I finished, there were two older men
in the corner dressed in traditional garb,
and they called over my translator.
And they stood there and one of them, he virtually
prayed over me.
Prayed over me.
The other one said to the translator, "Tell
her thank you.
Thank you for coming home as a descendant.
Thank you for representing and bringing intelligence
to this rap stuff.
And, you keep doing what you're doing because
what you're doing is important and people
need to know the positive side of the music
and the culture."
And I cried.
It was just so beautiful.
And it was the opposite of the warnings.
It was the complete opposite of what I was
warned about.
SIERRA: My last question for you is, the show
is called Why It Matters, we consistently
argue that things far away matter to you at
home, things at home matter to people far
away, whether or not we recognize it.
So, in that vein, why does hip-hop matter?
BLACKMAN: Hip-hop matters because it is art,
it is creativity, it is culture, it is connection,
it is community.
It is a way for us people around the world,
no matter what language we speak, no matter
our religion, our race, it is a way for us
to be connected, to be united.
And, if there's ever been a time in our history
when we need to be more on the same page,
it is now.
SIERRA: Hi everyone!
So just a heads up.
This is our last episode this season, we thought
we’d go out with a banger, get it, music
joke.
Anyway we will be back with more stories in
the fall.
Until then, definitely check out our show
notes page, because we have some really special
treats, including a list of international
hip hop artists that have worked with Toni!
So definitely go check it out!Special thanks
to all the wonderful artists that we sampled
in this episode.
And we’d also like to thank PBS whose documentary
Jazz Ambassadors was greatly greatly helpful.
And we encourage you to check that out too.
Have a question or some feedback?
Just feel like saying hi?
Send us an email at whyitmatters@cfr.org.
Subscribe to the show on Apple Podcasts, Spotify,
Stitcher, or wherever you get your audio.
And if you are a fan, we’d love it if you
could leave us a review.
Ideally a good one, the more stars the better.
We say this a lot but it really does help
us get noticed.
Why It Matters is a production of the Council
on Foreign Relations.
The show is produced by Asher Ross and me,
Gabrielle Sierra.
Our sound designer is Markus Zakaria.
Rafaela Siewert is our associate podcast producer.
And this semester’s intern was Roshni Rangwani.
Robert McMahon is our Managing Editor, and
Doug Halsey is our Chief Digital Officer.
Extra help for this episode was provided by
Claire Felter.
Original music is composed by Ceiri Torjussen.
Additional thanks go to Richard Haass, Jeff
Reinke, and our co-creator Jeremy Sherlick.
For Why It Matters, this is Gabrielle Sierra
signing off.
See you soon!